blast light is the world's smallest
and most convenient uvc disinfection
light to help keep you safe
against covid19 i take mine everywhere i
go
go to davidpakman.com light to get it
for 40
off the link is down below welcome
everybody
so i want to start today with what i see
as the impossibility of the current
culture war
being won by either the left or the
right but for
very different reasons and on friday i'm
going to talk a little bit more about
the republican strategy of doing culture
war issues instead of policy
but what i want to explain today is that
the culture war
that's currently taking place that's the
the one wherein the republican party has
completely abandoned policy
and instead they are fighting
politically on issues like critical race
theory socialism communism
flags sports team names
trans girls in sports the vague notion
of
that of fighting against what they claim
is the left wanting to defund the police
even though that's not what the left
wants to do
that type of thing is what i'm talking
about this is a war
that the left can't actually win in
fighting it on an issue-by-issue basis
and i'll explain why
but it's also a culture war that the
right has no interest in winning that's
a really important thing to understand
because the right benefits from it being
an ongoing war
as a strategy to justify people donating
money to them
and voting for them in elections because
you need them to continue fighting the
war
if they win the war then it's over the
entire impetus for saying
these are the reasons you need to donate
to us and here's why we don't actually
talk about policy
goes away if they win so they can never
actually win for their own
self-preservation
there's a really interesting article
from about two or three months ago in
politico magazine
called how the culture war could break
democracy
zack stanton wrote it and in the article
zach references james davis and hunter
sociologists from the university of
virginia who years ago
described culture war as
cultural flash points with political
ramifications
and that's a really good definition
these are
flashpoints meaning places events or
times when trouble
violence or anger flare up flashpoints
on the basis of cultural disagreements
but they're not just irrelevant cultural
disagreements
they have political significance in a
very real way
think through some examples the
so-called debate over critical race
theory is actually a really good example
of this this is a flash point
that is really a cultural issue what is
the culture in schools that the left
versus the right
wants what's the culture of workplaces
when it comes to a race and an
understanding of race
that is generating disagreement and
unrest and it's politically significant
in that republicans and the right are
weaponizing it to justify people voting
for them
instead of voting for democrats perfect
culture war
example now why do i say it's not
apparent to me that the culture war is
winnable
and i want to be really careful in how i
explain this as far as the american
right wings
right wing goes republicans don't have a
plan to win the culture war
because the winning is to continue
fighting the culture war forever as i
mentioned earlier
all of these cultural issues even when
they subside
in real life the right keeps talking
about them as if they are real problems
the entire war on christmas is a very
good example of this
that was always merely a cultural issue
and it was being laid on top of ideas of
nationalism
freedom of religion alleged hostility
from the left against religion
patriotism and even after the subject of
whether we say merry christmas or happy
holidays
essentially disappeared completely like
at some point it just went away it
wasn't even a thing
republicans continued to act as though
the very same war on christmas continued
to take place almost as an aside like of
course yeah we're also
still fighting the war on christmas even
though it wasn't actually
an issue in society so the point is
republicans don't plan to actually win
the culture war
because they benefit by fighting it
whether they win it or they lose it or
they have the majority public opinion
on their side or against their side they
will continue to claim
that the culture war is going on and
that it must be fought
and they are the people to fight it so
you'd better donate to them and vote for
them
so they can fight it for you that's uh
what's happening right now
with socialism and communism i mean look
at these last six months of joe biden
joe biden's first six months in office
it's become very clear joe biden is not
a communist
joe biden is not a socialist joe biden
is not a marxist now
if you'd been paying attention for the
last four decades you would know that
about joe biden
but now that joe biden is president and
he's done no socialist
stuff he's done no communist stuff
have the discussions about biden's
communism
and socialism gone away from the right
no because for republicans
especially in the absence of any policy
and in particular
especially when the country is
increasingly not with republicans
on policy they need to have some war
to point to so now they point to we've
got to fight communism and socialism
trump did it at his speech his rally in
phoenix on saturday which we covered
yesterday
so republicans have no plan to win the
culture war that's a feature not a bug
all right fine but what about the left
what about democrats what about
progressives however you define
that movement the unfortunate thing
is that these cultural issues aren't
actually won
by fighting them directly and there's a
couple of reasons for that and i think a
perfect example to understand this
is abortion rights abortion rights is an
issue
that the right has fought in two ways
the right has fought
against abortion rights as a cultural
issue
in churches and through colloquial
rhetoric but the right has
also fought abortion rights as a legal
issue ever since
we saw roe v wade legalize abortion in
most cases decades ago
we've seen republicans fight abortion
rights at the state level
in a legal sense and then they've also
fought it as a cultural issue on
television and
as an issue of we must preserve life and
humanity even the term pro-life is a
propaganda term you use
when you are fighting this as a cultural
issue you're framing anybody who doesn't
share your view
is against life there's no coincidence
about the right choosing the term
pro-life for their position
and the american right has essentially
lost the abortion fight
uh in in a legal sense what i mean by
that
and in a cultural sense what i mean by
that is while some states have
successfully curtailed abortion rights
with state-level restrictions it's still
a fight in that sense we're that still
is being legislated in the courts but we
have a situation today in 2021 where the
country is more in favor of abortion
being legal in most cases
than at any time in the last 40 years
republicans have been fighting abortion
for 40 years or even longer
and the country is more in favor of
abortion being legal in most cases today
than at any previous point it's an
abject failure by republicans by the
right
to fight against abortion rights but
that's not because democrats go around
talking about how great abortion is and
that's one of the complexities of
fighting the culture war
because of the way that the right frames
these issues and they do a good job of
it
i have to give them credit the left is
put in a position where if you fight
them directly head on on the issue
you get framed as oh well so you want
more abortions
and then all of a sudden now you're
fighting against that and it becomes a
mess
but then here's the other thing bigger
picture
the culture in the u.s has shifted
and as a result of that issues like
income inequality and the environment
have taken more center stage and
opposition to abortion has just faded
so a lot of the reason that the soft
opposition to abortion has gone away
isn't because of democrats going around
and saying abortion is great
it's because a lot of people realized
yeah we actually don't even really need
to be talking about that
we need to be talking about income
inequality and access to health care
and the damage we're doing to the
environment etc it's not
a fight that makes sense and so with a
lot of these things
i don't know that there's anything to
win by fighting issues head on
i'll think now about critical race
theory which is a great example
republicans make critical race theory
out to be this
absolute evil thing that will corrupt
your children
it will lead to self-hating whites it
will lead your kids down some kind of
marxist rabbit hole or whatever the case
may be
and progressives in order to fight it
head-on
mostly have to talk about critical race
theory is great
even if they don't believe that it's
great or maybe they're just not sure
as a progressive myself i don't have
much of an interest
in defending critical race theory in and
of itself
because i see it as i mean listen
critical race theory is one of many
critical theories
it's important to understand them it's
important to study them
and like any post-modern post-structural
structuralist critical theory
it has significant limitations it's just
one little aspect
of how we might analyze the world around
us so what exactly would
would be the fight like i'm not
interested in going around demanding
critical race theory specifically be
taught in schools
but it certainly shouldn't be banned i'm
not interested in going around extolling
the endless virtues of critical race
theory
but it should be understood among many
other ways
of analyzing the world around us what
i'm interested in
is moving society on from the thought
that critical race theory is even an
important issue
that it should get the amount of oxygen
that it's getting and so
when i say the left is not going to win
the culture war
what i mean is it's not going to win on
these individual issues
arguing about should the cleveland
indians be called the indians or the
guardians and and why and that
making that a for a forefront issue or
at what
age should critical race theory start to
be taught
the complexity is and here's where i
turn to you for ideas
the complexity is that if you just
ignore these issues if you ignore the
war on christmas you ignore
the fight that the right is waging
against critical race theory
etc you allow the right to secure
some real victories in controlling
society which
we don't want them to do but at the same
time
if you fight these issues one by one you
either
end up spending a lot of time defending
things that you're not even really that
much in favor of at the end of the day
you just don't think they should be
banned for example
so what is the balance between
understanding that fighting these issues
on their merits is essentially a losing
battle
while at the same time recognizing that
if we ignore these issues completely
that's not a good idea either because we
seed so much ground to the right so
that's my question to you
given that the right doesn't plan to
actually win the culture war
and given that fighting each of these
cultural issues for the left is
essentially a losing battle
how is it that the left should face up
against this because republicans have
made it very clear
they're done with policy sure they'll
say keep the to keep the deficit down or
they'll say build a wall or whatever but
i mean listen the the wall was never
going to happen you can
even saying the wall was an example of
policy no it wasn't it was never going
to get built
mexico was never going to pay for it it
was really a it was a metaphorical wall
all along um and so my question to you
is what is the proper
uh how should the left enter this and
manage it given that republicans
seem extremely committed to no more
policy
and just fighting cultural issues quick
reminder we are just a few weeks
from the 16th anniversary of the david
pakman show we're doing something very
special on august 16th that's the day
at the end of august 16th midnight it
will be the 16th anniversary of the show
so all day august 16th we're going to be
doing
a very special and borderline
over-the-top membership discount if
you've been thinking ah maybe i'll sign
up maybe i won't
this is the time to do it get on my
mailing list at joinpackman.com
at davidpakman.com rather and you'll be
notified
first thing monday morning august 16th
about how to
sign up for this incredible membership
special
one of our sponsors is blastlight the
smallest
and most convenient uv disinfection
light on the market
covet is not over there are new variants
there might be future resurgences so of
course it's still important to take
precautions keep yourself safe keep
people around you
safe uvc lights have been proven to
safely and rapidly kill
bacteria mold fungi and viruses
including covet 19.
blast light is a convenient keychain uvc
light that you can take
wherever you go i keep it attached to my
keys
it goes everywhere with me it's easy to
use it disinfects any surface in just
seconds
with a really long battery life and it's
rechargeable i've looked at a bunch of
different uvc light
options and this is by far the most
compact and portable one out there
blast light is normally 99 but my
audience can get it for 40
off which comes to 59.50 when you go to
davidpakman.com
blastlight the link is underneath this
video
remember that the david pakman show is
sponsored primarily made possible
primarily
funded primarily by viewers and
listeners like you we do an entire
extra show for our members every single
day
we've got this show that you're
listening to right now that you're
watching right now
that finishes then we do an extra show
just for our website members you can
sign up at joinpacman.com
you will get the daily bonus show as
well as commercial free audio and video
feeds of the show but it just feels good
even if you got nothing i would argue it
would still be worth it to know you're
funding an alternative to homogeneous
corporate media but because you get so
much great free stuff with it why not
right sign up at joinpackman.com you
know um
i as many of you are i'm watching
very closely vaccination numbers
coveted case numbers deaths etc we're
trying to figure out
are we headed towards hell again in the
fall
what is happening with the delta variant
what about the next variant what's
happening in europe which seems to
sort of be a leading indicator for what
we might expect here in the united
states and so on and so forth and then
you just look at what's happening around
the country
and you realize hey guys uh
they're fighting against us they they're
so the anti-vaxx
right wing has become a monster
essentially of its own making
so big that they may prevent the country
from being as great as they claim to
want it to be they talk about make
america great again
they talk about america first they talk
about all this stuff
and then they don't want to get
vaccinated which is what will help the
economy
and it will help prevent death and it
will help prevent hospitalization
and i want to look at some video with
you today
of arkansas republican governor governor
asa hutchinson
now i don't want to go overboard in my
praise of republicans
but i want to mention that in the last
week or so
many prominent republican leaders have
started being much more positive about
covet vaccines i think it's basically
motivated by
economic concerns and the realization
that it's increasingly becoming a
republican virus
because republicans want vaccinations at
such a lower rate
than democrats overwhelmingly you are
seeing
red counties republican counties have a
higher per capita
case rate okay so governor asa
hutchinson does
an event with state vaccine official dr
jennifer
delaha and he says very
basic simple things like the vaccine
doesn't cause infertility which is one
conspiracy that's been floating around
and he gets booed listen to this
does this impact fertility well the
answer is no
and that's been the data but they
what kind of person boos the news
that hey great news the vaccine doesn't
impact fertility as far as we know right
now based on all the evidence we've seen
they've created a monster they can't
control
hutchinson then defers to the state's
vaccine authority
and it just gets very ugly doctor
do you want to answer that so at this
point it's delayha not dillaha i
apologize
in time there is no evidence
[Applause]
this is the same energy from from which
burnings
right i mean it's that they will not
hear any alternative view to this is a
witch
these are lies about vaccines
[Applause]
go ahead dr so there is no medical
evidence at this time
that the copic vaccines impact fertility
there is a great deal of evidence
that the copic illness itself
causes problems with pregnancy
and fetal demise so i think so
understand that
the evidence isn't that the vaccine
causes
fertility issues the evidence is covid
can cause issues with
pregnancy how do you talk rationally
with these people i mean how
reach across the aisle who who are you
reaching out to
um and this is something that we're
getting more and more information about
i think it's worth repeating
women's periods and the immune system
are connected
uh as a woman is about to ovulate her
immune system
ramps itself up to prevent any
infectious agent from interfering
with the start of a pregnancy with the
fertilization and implantation of the
egg
once that egg is fertilized and then
implants
the immune system dampens to accept
the pregnancy the uterus has immune
cells
those can be affected by hormonal
changes the immune system and cortisol
which is the stress hormone
those are related and periods respond
to cortisol levels so the long and short
of it is
there are anecdotal reports of a late
period
in some women after the second dose of
the vaccine
it's possible that the covid vaccines
could impact one or maybe two periods
following the second dose in terms of a
delay for example
because the immune system of the woman
is hard at work developing
immunity or because of cortisol
levels as dr delaha is stating
there is no evidence of an impact on
fertility
there's no evidence of any long-term
effects
and there is evidence that a bigger risk
to pregnancy than being vaccinated
is getting covered for a pregnant woman
but
the crowd doesn't want to hear it so
again for everybody saying
we've got to just relate to these people
we've got to reach across the aisle get
them vaccinated
i'm with you but how do you do that
where
they literally start chanting they
become
i i hate to use a term that is uh
a portmanteau created by former producer
lewis they become
feverent yeah i know it's not a word but
you can look that one up on urban
dictionary
how do you calm them down they're
experiencing this outrageous state of
like a hyper arousal where they just
can't stop screaming when a doctor is
simply saying there's no evidence of
that
i don't know how you connect with those
people but it is
very scary stuff in terms of what it
means for the united states
reaching hurt immunity if that's even
still something we think we might be
able to do
i want to look again at
one of the uh false notions
that is being spread by the right
when the topic of cannabis of marijuana
comes up this is sort of like a perfect
storm of a bunch of different stories
first of all the clip we're going to
look at uh is from
fox and friends fox and friends has been
i guess you could say applauded a little
bit in the last week because
steve ducey has started to say get the
vaccine if you can get it and there are
people saying oh
fox and friends now is pro-vaccine as
we've said before
brian kilmeade on fox and friends has
not changed his mind apparently on
vaccines or whatever the case may be
so let's kind of uh dampen our praise of
fox and friends
second issue the story of increased
violent crime
in the united states through the
pandemic which right-wing media wants to
exclusively blame on
joe biden even though the increase in
crime actually started under trump's
watch during the pandemic
and then number three any opportunity to
criticize marijuana or cannabis
depending on how you prefer to refer to
it
they take advantage of that and in this
particular clip fox news
suggests violent crime is up
because of people smoking pot take a
listen to this
when you walk out in the streets of new
york city you said it
smelled like urine and pot okay
not a great morning show image but it's
true
but the pot part is particularly
important because
after the shooting in washington dc on
thursday night
on friday the chief cop in washington dc
made a connection that too few
leaders in democratic-run towns are
doing and that is he finds a direct
connection between the violence
and pot usage here's robert conte
we have taken on a mindset that
marijuana is not really
it's not really a big issue in our city
i can tell you that marijuana
undoubtedly
is connected to violent crimes that
we're seeing in our communities
when you have something where people get
high reward they can make a lot of money
by selling illegal marijuana and the
risk is low
the risk for accountability is very low
that creates
a very very very very very bad situation
because those individuals get robbed
those individuals get shot at
those individuals get involved in
disputes all across our city
i'm seeing it happen more and more and
he's not alone
in other cities they're doing as well
but what are they going to do
it's hard to put the toothpaste back in
the tube they've legalized pot in a
bunch of places
and now they've seen violent crime spike
you're gonna say you know what we made a
mistake well they should because
obviously yeah no the chief's numbers
support what he said
i'm really glad that the chief brought
this up because it's a very uh touchy
topic because pot has just been so
normalized in our culture
but he brings up the point that there is
a nexus between pot and and violent
crime and it's not just
the buying and selling um you know it
has mental health effects
you have a higher chance of
schizophrenia of having psychosis i mean
there's actual data behind that people
ignore that and the pot lobby is very
powerful it is
very powerful um and and and they're
normalizing it with our children
if you if you come out against it you're
just an old fuddy daddy well and and
what the chief said he said look
uh there are people who are being robbed
to buy
to get the money to buy more pot right
uh senator schumer tries
is going to try to make it nash become
in that okay so so they're mixing up
like three different issues
it all kind of feels like reefer madness
2021 so so let's kind of go through
these things one by one
first of all is the effect of the uh
uh cannabis on individuals propensity to
be violent that's the
you might be confused and saying wait
what is the argument is the argument
about the illegal drug trade or is it
about consumption of cannabis
they're mixing it all together first of
all marijuana doesn't make people
violent as a general rule
alcohol often does which is completely
legal
alcohol is actually a major factor in
violent crime
marijuana is not there's a very
interesting study
called subjective aggression during
alcohol and cannabis intoxication
before and after aggression exposure
what the study did was
it exposed people to aggression through
something called
point subtraction aggression paradigm
and the single category implicit
association test
you don't need to know what that is but
the findings here are
that quote subjective aggression
significantly
increased following aggression exposure
in
all groups while being sober alcohol
intoxication
increased subjective aggression whereas
cannabis
decreased the subjective aggression
following
aggression exposure aggressive responses
during the psap
increased following alcohol and
decreased following cannabis
relative to placebo what this is telling
us is that when people are
sober and you do what's called
aggression exposure in a way that that
has been scientifically determined this
is how you sort of like
uh trigger can trigger an aggression
response from people
uh people's level of aggression goes up
alcohol
is an aggravating factor in generating
that aggressive aggressive response
cannabis is a mitigating factor so
that's one piece and that's really
important to understand
so uh uh that you know when they talk
about cannabis and making people violent
it's like hey let's look
maybe look at rock and roll as well like
it again it just feels
like a 40 year old argument that's been
widely uh debunked
aside from the pharmacological impact
there's the other side of it which is
that legalization
reduces violence it reduces violence
it is far less likely that there will be
violence
when buying pot at a hipster weed store
compared to in a back alley from
street dealers that you don't know now
their argument is
if the penalties for the dealing go down
then you are going to see more dealers
enter the market
but it it's not actually working that
way because when it's legalized and
regulated
the demand for buying from street
dealers goes down dramatically now will
some people
want to pay less even when there's
legalization to go and buy for from a
street dealer who doesn't have to pay
tax
yeah to some degree but the net effect
is a reduction
in cannabis distribution related
violence
and then lastly how do you not mention
350 million guns in the united states
when you look at all of these other
countries that have decriminalized
legalized marijuana and you look at the
united states
you would immediately notice 350 million
guns in the united states
that's not a factor but somehow the weed
is the factor you got to be just kidding
me with this stuff and
it's unfortunate because again there's
people who want to be told this is
really dangerous
and so they see this and they agree with
it at the end of the day
where do you worry more about violence
the bar
down the street or a room full of
stoners playing video games i mean
it's a silly way to sort of go to the
fundamentals of this
but think about that and then look at
the placebo controlled studies
including the one that i mentioned
earlier these people make no sense
uh they are looking for an explanation
for their pre-existing views rather than
actually being open
to following the science we'll have more
on this story on the david pakman show
instagram
find us at david pakman show you can
find me on instagram at david.pakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire archive of
every episode dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
it's great to have back on the program
today rick doblin who's the founder and
executive director of
maps the multi-disciplinary association
for psychedelic
studies which researches um
legal developing legal contexts for the
careful and beneficial uses of
psychedelics and marijuana
rick it's great to have you back on
today yes it's my pleasure i look
forward to our discussion
so i want to eventually get to what some
of the advancements and developments
have been since you and i last spoke a
couple of years ago
uh but first you you mentioned that you
were recently
in texas with a bunch of republicans
including
dan crenshaw who is not known typically
as the
progressive beacon of hope to the left
um
but there seemed to be some sort of
camaraderie on the issue of using
psychedelics for
for uh veterans and in other contexts
yeah well uh representative crenshaw is
a former navy seal
right and he's heard now from quite a
number of navy seals who have
ptsd traumatic brain injury and the
treatments that they've been getting
from the va
haven't been helping them and so there's
a group called vets
by amber and marcus capone that brings
particularly navy seals down to mexico
for ibogaine which is a psychedelic drug
from western africa
and also 5meodmt which is a drug from
the sonoran toad
it's the most powerful of all the
psychedelics
and these navy seals have been finding a
lot of relief and other veterans as well
and so they've been sharing the news
with dan crenshaw
and also he's been hearing with some of
the veterans and others in our studies
with
mdma for ptsd and so now he has become a
major advocate
and he's working of all bipartisan way
with um uh
tim ryan who's the congressman from ohio
friend of the show
very good guy yeah he's fantastic so
that they're the two of them though are
working together
we're getting ready to launch a bill to
give 25 million to the department of
defense
for psychedelic research for ptsd and
then another bill to give
25 million to the va and so what we're
finding is that
the healing of veterans and others with
trauma from trauma is bipartisan
and one of the things that was so
interesting at the
discussion with dan crenshaw is here i
am surrounded by texas republicans
and i talked about how maps is a
non-profit we've raised over 115 million
dollars in donations to do this research
over our 35 years and i started by
saying that we've got this bipartisan
support
and i talked about rebecca mercer who
was the uh
family big supporters of trump and
bannon owned cambridge analytica which
we know about
scraping all the data from facebook so i
said we have support from rebecca mercer
from elizabeth coke whose father is
charles koch
and we have support from the rockefeller
family the
buffett family the pritzkers and i said
it goes all the way to george soros who
also supports us
and there was kind of this sort of
initial kind of joke or groan that
dan crenshaw made about george soros but
in the end it was like oh
it was like we're all in it together
that was the
the dominant message uh there was one
thing that was really surprising to me
too which was afterwards there was a
a woman who's um a therapist used to be
a therapist
at the houston va and she does
uh what's called emdr which is an
approach towards helping people with
ptsd
and we she talked about her husband was
a veteran and
um she's helped him with ptsd she's very
interested in our research
and then she said she's actually running
for congress i said that's really good
and then she said yeah and i'm running
against a republican
i said all right so we talked it was
like we
we took exchanged cards it was very
interesting and then i got home to write
her a little
email and i discovered that she's
running as a republican
against a republican who's not
sufficiently right-wing
but she likes what you're doing she
likes what we're doing because she likes
healing veterans so you've been
somehow or other able to take
psychedelics and
healing of trauma and move it out of
this
uh partisan struggle and it seems like
it's
it's going pretty well in that way yeah
that's it's an it's an incredible thing
and um i mean i would be curious to hear
since we last talked there were so many
things you were researching there were
so many things that you were studying
what are the sort of tangible
advancements
that have been made in this field of
using psychedelics and
as well as sometimes cannabis uh for for
a lot of different situations well-being
etc what advancements have we made in
the last couple of years
well in may we published we meaning maps
the we published the results from our
first phase three study of mdma assisted
psychotherapy for ptsd
you have to do two phase three studies
to get a drug approved by fda and they
have to approve safety and efficacy
and the first study was published in
nature medicine which is one of the most
highest impact scientific journals in
the world
and we had outstanding results better
than we even had hoped
and so what we showed is highly
significant results statistically
significant
large effect size excellent safety
record
the most amazing part is we work with
the hardest cases meaning
severe ptsd chronic ptsd
unlike many ptsd studies we enroll
people who've previously attempted
suicide
and what we showed is that two months
after the last experimental session
two-thirds of these people no longer had
ptsd
it's just astounding the control group
was 32 percent
that's the group that got therapy
without mdma so 32 almost one-third no
longer had ptsd
from our therapy but when you add mdma
to the therapy it's
67 percent no longer have ptsd and of
the one-third that still
has ptsd most of them had what's called
clinically significant reductions of
ptsd symptoms
so we are the only group there that's in
phase three with psychedelics there's
now about a hundred plus psychedelic
companies for-profit companies
a few non-profits and they're either in
earlier
stages of the research or they're trying
to develop new molecules that they can
patent new psychedelics
but we're the only ones in phase three
so that's the main development
there's also groups that have been
working with psilocybin
and they're doing well in phase two and
it's psilocybin for depression
psilocybin for
nicotine addiction psilocybin for
alcoholism
psilocybin for obsessive-compulsive
disorder
we've also completed studies with
psilocybin excuse me with mdma for
social anxiety for life threat people
anxious about life-threatening illnesses
there was an incredible study done by
others that we helped with
david nutt and ben sesson england mdma
for alcohol use disorder
what it turns out is that trauma is what
drives a lot of drug addiction if you
help people deal with the traumas of
life
then they don't need to run away in
drugs and so we were able to show good
results in that
there's also starting to be interesting
promising findings with traumatic brain
injury that certain psychedelics can be
helpful with that
there's just a whole range of studies
that are now being
started with psychedelics that
are really showing enormous progress and
and one of the main
things that we know is that psychedelics
promote what's called neuroplasticity
and what that means is that our brains
are not fixed
they evolve as we grow we know that when
we remember things there's something
changed in our brain but more
importantly psychedelics can promote
new neural connections in
different kind of pathways so for ptsd
we've there's been neuroscientists at
johns hopkins gul dolan who
did work with mdma giving them to
octopuses and giving mdma to mice
uh for the octopuses they're very
solitary creatures
and they stay away from other octopuses
unless it's mating season which is the
end of their life
but you give them mdma and now they want
to hang out with other octopuses
and so these kind of pre-verbal deep in
our evolutionary history
mdma has this profound impact but in
mice when you give
mdma to mice it promotes oxytocin
release
which is the hormone of love they call
it the cuddle hormone
the love nursing mothers and
it promotes new neural connections new
growth of
neurons in new pathways
what happens in these studies when with
the studies with people
is there like a placebo group where do
people know whether they're getting
the mdma or not because that seems like
it would be a relevant question in terms
of measuring the impact right
yeah that's a great question um my
dissertation at the kennedy school of
government
uh where i got my master's in phd was on
the regulation of the medical use of
psychedelics and one of the main things
i looked at was how do you do a
double-blind
study with a drug like a psychedelic
that's pretty obvious if you've taken it
it's not like you're taking different
pills and you don't notice
automatically what they do these are
very powerful drugs that change your
consciousness
and you usually can tell if that's
happening sure so
a lot of my dissertation was about how
to solve this problem and
i thought i had the solution the
solution i thought was going to be
therapy with low dose mdma versus
therapy with full dose mdma
and the challenge was to find the dose
of mdma that was
high enough that enough people would
notice it
and would not be certain was it the low
dose or the high dose
but that it wasn't so high that you
started getting all the therapeutic
potentials of mdma
and this is what we explored in phase
two
so maps i started in 1986 we started our
first phase one
safety study in 1992 and in 1999 and
2000 we started the phase two studies
and that took us till 2016.
but what we discovered and this is i
guess you could say the
the beauty and humility of scientific
research
is that you discover stuff that you
didn't realize was
actually going on or you discover that
you were wrong so what i discovered
through these studies and we tested uh
inactive placebo
with therapy 25 milligrams 30 milligrams
40 milligrams 50 milligrams 75
milligrams 100 125 and 150
and what we showed is that the
therapeutic dose
was lower than we thought 75 milligrams
was very
effective but that the lower doses
they did cause a certain amount of
inaccurate guesses
but what they did is they had an
anti-therapeutic effect
meaning that everybody still got better
who got these lower therapy plus lower
doses but
when we looked at the data the people
that had therapy without mdma did better
than the people that had therapy with
low-dose mdma
and the best way to describe it it's
like if you're in an airplane and you're
about to take off sometimes there's
turbulence at the beginning
and then you get above the clouds and
then it's smooth sailing
so the low doses of mdma were like this
turbulence they
people were focused on their trauma they
were activated a little bit but the fear
reduction properties of mdma
weren't fully activated so right made
people uncomfortable
so when we went to the fda to design
phase three
um i opened it up by saying that there's
a funny quote by a former president of
harvard
and what he said was never forget
there's always a harvard man on the
wrong side of
every issue and so i said
in this case it's me my dissertation
which fortunately i managed to get
my theory was wrong and that there is no
solution to the double-blind problem
and so he said to the fda we can give
you the blinding but you're going to
make it
easier for us to find a difference
between the two groups and the real
question is
if you can do this work with therapy
without adding a drug
why add the drug so rather than adding a
drug that gives a little bit of
blinding it's more important that we
test the therapy by itself where it's
the most effective
and so the fda brought in what we like
to joke as the old wise man of the fda
his name is bob temple
and he's been there since 1972 and he
was the office of science policy and he
came and he said
there is he agreed there is no solution
to the double-blind problem
and he said that there there are other
ways to try to
reduce experiment or bias the double
blind is really to make it so that
you know you don't get biased results
that you don't find what you want to
find
right and so what what they first off
said is what's called random assignment
that means
everybody is similarly motivated and
then they get randomized either to the
control group or the
experimental group the other thing they
said is that
the independent raters who evaluate
the outcomes that you can't have the
therapist say oh did this person get
better or not or even the person
themselves
to to do it that you need independent
raters
and this is done through an hour-long
interview with the patient about all of
their symptoms
and so we have these independent raiders
in a very robust system we have over 20
of them trained by the boston veterans
administration
where they develop the measure they do
it by random assignment
meaning it's all telemedicine so they
don't know
the patient where they are in the
treatment process
they don't know if they've got mdma or
the placebo so
based on that the fda said that they
would agree with us that we would do
therapy without mdma versus therapy with
mdma
even still there's about 10 of the
people that are confused
about what they got which is pretty
astonishing but sometimes people
resist the emotional effects of mdma
because they're so scared of what's
going on they have kind of a muted
effect
so there's a little bit of confusion but
we also negotiated with the european
medicines agency we're trying to
negotiate all over the world to
globalize mdma therapy
and so the european medicines agency
went through the same analysis and they
also agreed with the fda
that it's therapy without mdma versus
therapy
with mdma and therapy with inactive
placebo
and we're also doing research in israel
and canada
we've done some in brazil we're just
moving forward into australia
so i think the the frustrating part in a
way is that there is no good solution to
the double-blind problem but
the fda realizes that that even though
the methodology doesn't work
people are still suffering you still
have to do the research and you still
have to design the studies as best you
can
right so the breakthrough that we had
was uh
our first phase three study being
tremendously successful and so we are
now doing the second phase three study
we do have a site here in boston and
many of your listeners may have heard of
a book called the body keeps the score
and it's by a fellow bessel vanderkok
who's a psychiatrist here in boston
amazingly by the way he published the
book six years ago
about trauma and two weeks ago it was
the number one best-selling book on the
new york times bestseller list of
print and e-book combinations so there's
an enormous cultural interest now in
trauma
and bessel is the principal investigator
of our boston site
and he thinks that uh mdma is the most
effective thing he's seen for ptsd in
his entire career
yep so it's uh very much excited it's
incredible the advancements that are
being made and
uh yeah the body keeps the score great
really a great book for anybody to read
regardless of one situation a uh an
important book
uh rick always so glad to hear about the
things that are going on
one last thing please okay just just
that we think that the second phase
three study
we will have um completed in october of
2022.
okay and we think by the end of 2023 we
expect to have
fda approval and then we're training
we want to train 25 000 therapists
and set up thousands of psychedelic
clinics throughout the united states and
thousands more throughout the world
ambitious and uh fantastic
rick davlin from from maps always so
great speaking to you rick
great thank you for having me
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com david pakman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show
michael flynn used to be national
security advisor he was national
security advisor
for a relatively short period of time to
the former president donald trump
and flynn has been caught on video
saying
about a rifle that he was gifted that
maybe he'll find someone
in washington dc to use the rifle
against
this is the very same former trump
national security adviser who was
indicted and later pardoned by donald
trump
flynn has been appearing at various
events across the country
and he did one at a california church i
don't know what about
flynn makes him good material for church
appearances i don't i admit i'm not like
an expert in the teachings of jesus
but something about this guy doesn't
strike me as good material for a church
but specifically this was at the church
of glad tidings
in yuba city california they gifted
flynn
an assault style rifle and then flynn
made the remark about maybe i'll find
somebody
in washington dc uh let's take a look at
the video
[Applause]
that's awesome and tell us about your
gift
yeah so
we were trying to come up with a rifle
that we thought was appropriate for a
general
so we went with the old-school woodland
camouflage
so anyhow this is uh one of our
top quality guns and maybe i'll find
somebody in washington d.c
and the crowd cheers about maybe finding
someone in dc
with his new shiny rifle
consider the level of humiliation that
this
country is enduring globally thanks to
the vestiges of the prior administration
donald trump continues to insist that he
won an election that he lost
and the world laughs we continue to
struggle to get people vaccinated
because of the anti-vaccine sentiment
that exists overwhelmingly in trump
supporters
and the world cries because it affects
everyone
and now donald trump's own former
national security adviser michael flynn
gets a rifle as a gift and says maybe
i'll find
some people in washington and the world
is aghast at what is taking place in
this country
rachel vinman the wife of whistleblower
alexander vinman was among those
who rightly denounced flynn on twitter
she said that flynn should quote be
recalled to active duty
and court-martialed retired four-star
general barry mccaffrey last month
went after flynn because remember flynn
recently called the myanmar-like
uh called for a myanmar-like coup in the
united states at a q anon conference
mccaffrey said this is putting the
country at risk
i have never heard anything like this in
the last hundred years
this is completely irresponsible
provocative language and
quite frankly if this was anybody but
who it is a former trump administration
official but if it was some random guy i
suspect the fbi
or local law enforcement would be
immediately investigating
comments like this this is the guy who
encouraged
chance in front of crowds to lock up
hillary lock up whoever
he's done more to warrant being locked
up than they have by far
and if you were flynn why would you ease
up on this stuff right i mean
you were convicted they had you dead to
rights and then trump pardons you
and before you know it you're traveling
around the country getting gifts and
getting paid for bogus speaking
appearances
churches of all place it makes sense if
you were flynn
you would be feeling emboldened and by
the way speaking of churches
why is that church tax exempt why is any
church
tax exempt maybe churches that raise
money
to buy gifts of guns should not be tax
exempt
now i've talked about this before i
understand
that when i say churches shouldn't be
tax exempt
some people get mad and they write to me
and they say david
churches do education and schools are
tax exempt
churches sometimes run soup kitchens and
charities for the homeless and
those are normally tax exempt why would
you take that away
i have no problem with the church run
soup kitchen
as a standalone enterprise keeping its
own books and being a non-profit
even though it's a religious education i
don't even really have much of a problem
with a church run preschool or
kindergarten
being organized as its own entity and
getting non-profit status but a blanket
you pay no taxes on real estate you pay
no taxes on income
because that's really what it is it's
income because you have claimed
to be a religious entity under the law
that has to go
and it would be a real gold mine of
government tax revenue we could fund all
sorts of important things that people
love to say but how would we pay for
that
the washington post estimates this is an
eight-year-old estimate it's probably a
higher number now
that the u.s could make about 85 billion
per year
by eliminating subsidies on churches
where they get to pay no taxes that's
real
money with which a lot of good could be
done
and uh it just it's all backwards the
michael flynn thing is backwards
tax-exempt churches is backwards it's
all completely
backwards donald trump hired a new
spokeswoman a few months ago
she is dramatically and cartoonishly
more unhinged i would say
than any of donald trump's former
spokespeople her name is liz harrington
she went on fox news yesterday and she
claimed listen to this
she claimed that the arizona so-called
audit
of the 2020 election results now that's
the election from nine months ago
that's the one she says that the audit
in arizona
found provisionally 275
000 potential fraudulent ballots
she also says nearly four 000 were
falsely certified
and it's all trump trump won trump won
everything
according to her let's take a look at
this clip from fox news
that includes 106. here we go well if
you look at the preliminary findings
from the
independent audit already we have 275
000 potential fraudulent ballots
how many caveats are there if you look
at the preliminary findings preliminary
meaning
meaningless as of yet from the
independent
it's not an independent audit it's also
not
an audit there are 275
potential fraudulent ballots could there
be more
if sands and butts there guys i just
looked at five
potential vacation homes which have a
real
preliminary standing as homes that i
might buy
do you know what would happen if i
showed up and tried to get into those
homes
the police would be called and so the
point she wants to make
of course is trump won arizona let's
continue
includes 168 000 that were printed on
thin paper outside of the regulations of
maricopa county
you have 75 000 ballots that were
supposed to be mailed out but they have
no record of them ever being sent
you also have 18 000 voters who were
purged from the voter rolls
who voted in the election but were
purged after the election and
here's a significant one brett if i
could bring up that everything so far i
guess is not significant
now she's going to give us the real
significant stuff the county will not
touch
3981 people voted
despite registering after the october
15th
court order deadline and here's the key
question that means
maricopa county certified false results
and if we still have a free country with
one set of rules for every
every american this is a spokeswoman the
so it's bad enough when it's jenna ellis
or sydney powell or whatever
this is the this is the official
spokeswoman for the former president of
the united states donald trump
nine months after the election talking
about these fraudulent ballot dumps
the votes need to be thrown out
immediately or
do we live in a communist country our
votes
turn up 100 to nothing no that does not
say
for joseph stalin it says for joseph
biden
that's in fulton county georgia if we're
going to keep a country
free we need to have these audits to get
to the bottom of it because 100 to
nothing
is not the united states of america and
we need these audits to continue to get
to the true
results so completely delusional
completely delusional but the point she
wants to make is trump really won
arizona
remember the official results in arizona
are that joe biden won
but only by about 11 000 votes so
therefore you know if 275 000 ballots
were really
fraudulent then trump would have won
arizona easily that's the point
except it's all completely made up they
are potentially fraudulent
until they are verified and they were
verified within a day or two
of election day i actually have a
difficult time
getting a read on liz harrington i can't
tell if she's a liar or completely
delusional
something about how she talks doesn't
make it totally clear to me does she
believe this stuff
or is she actually living in a fantasy
world divorced from reality
uh is she going out and saying things
she knows to be lies maybe the two
aren't mutually exclusive maybe she's a
liar
and delusional in some sense
but the particularly horrifying part
is that millions of people in the united
states believe this there are millions
of people
in this country who will watch fox news
and they will hear liz harrington say we
found
on a preliminary basis 275
000 potentially fraudulent votes and to
them that means trump won arizona and
that joe biden stole it period without
question end of story and so much as is
the case with trump in general
the fact that trump existed wouldn't
have met much if there weren't tens of
millions of people willing to vote for
him
and the fact that liz harrington is
going around saying this stuff would
mean a lot less
if there weren't tens of millions of
people who believed it and it is a
really really ugly situation
i don't see any way to fix this and
speaking of things i don't see any way
how to fix
we get to today's voicemail we have a
voicemail number and you can call
anytime you want
the number is 2192davidp i've
essentially stopped playing any
voicemails from troy york
but um and he calls like four or five
times a day
but i want to play this voicemail
because it relates to something really
really sinister that's going on it
relates to vaccines take a listen
hey david pakman how how many videos are
are you and the lying media
going to continue to put out about
people who were anti-vaxxers
getting sick and dying in covet and why
don't you put out videos of the
numerous just as more numerous
most likely of people who have
received the vaccine and then they drop
dead within a
week to a month and the cover-up of
these uh
this number actually is much higher but
there are stories where they actually
pinpoint suggests of people through yeah
so this is this is totally made up so
there's two things that are going on
here
one um when you give tens of millions
or hundreds of millions of people a
vaccine and you start with the oldest
and most vulnerable folks
by sheer math some number of those
people
are going to die because people die
and then to attribute it to a vaccine
when we have no reason to think the
vaccine had anything to do with it
doesn't make sense the second thing that
troy may be referring to
is that there's a vaccine side effect
reporting system called v-a-e-r-s and
maybe i'll do a story about this
v-a-e-r-s or vares i believe it's it's
said in shorthand
is being targeted with massive
dumps of bogus vaccine side effect and
death submissions
anti-vaxxers are going to the vares
system
and just making up submissions and then
anti-vaxx publications are taking that
bogus data
and putting out reports on that basis
it's a major problem
maybe we'll do a segment on it but as
usual troy york completely divorced from
reality
we have a great bonus show for you today
sign up at joinpackman.com i'll see you
then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blastlight is the world's smallest and
most convenient
uvc disinfection light to help keep you
safe against covid19 i take mine
everywhere i go
go to davidpakman.com blastlight to get
it for 40
off the link is down below